want to get your thoughts on this the
view ripped as quote unquote tone deaf
or its discussion about queen
elizabeth's covid diagnosis take a
listen
this also comes at the same time that
the queen canceled her engagements after
she got covered so could boris be
jumping the gun on this or is this part
of what we're going to be seeing did the
queen go to his parties
it's kind of tone deaf right at this
point to announce this on the eve of the
queen announcing that she's contracted
covet i mean they have one job and
that's to protect the queen and they
couldn't even do that
as a doctor who's trying to get us
through this pandemic you want to hear
things like that on tv
it's it's ridiculous really you know you
have to take into consideration the
words that could potentially be causing
instilling fear in others look i think
what boris johnson has done is perfectly
correct that's what the united states
should be doing she picked up omicron
from likely from her son because it's
extremely contagious she did what she
had to do she's triple vaccinated her
symptoms are mild but again when you see
that the level of positive cases in the
community is extremely low and almost
gone we have to scale back our
mitigation efforts we can't live with
masks and mandates forever it's time to
move on know your risk protect yourself
get your vaccine and move on with our
lives dr jeannette neshwa we always
appreciate your time thanks so much for
joining us